dieser nun entdeckte exoplanet ist der
erde ähnlicher als alle anderen
exoplaneten die in der nähe unserer erde
entdeckt worden sind bisher keppler 16
49 c ist ja lediglich muss man sagen 300
lichtjahre von uns entfernt und kreist
in der habitablen zone seines sterns
doch wie lebensfreundlich sind die
bedingungen hier und es gibt noch eine
tatsächlich bahnbrechende neuerung bei
pixum dir hören nämlich auf und fangen
an womit mehr infos am ende des videos
geldsumme science fiction her gibt es
täglich spannendes heinz videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen klicks und
gibt es übrigens jetzt auch als podcast
der link zu spotify und apple ist unten
in der video beschreibung unbedingt mal
reinhören ist prima für unterwegs
es ist schon fast ein eher zwilling der
exilant keppler
16 49 c ist 1,06 mal so groß wie unsere
erde also fast gleich gross und bekommt
75 prozent der lichteinstrahlung somit
sollten hier nur leicht kühlere
temperaturen vorherrschen als auf der
erde er liegt rund 300 lichtjahre von
uns entfernt und kreis in der habitablen
zone seines sterns die sonne dieses
exoplaneten leuchtet allerdings nicht
gelb sowie unsere sondern rot der grund
dafür seien zentral stern ist ein roter
zwerg im klartext heißt das also denn
nun aufgespürt der exoplanet ist der
erde nicht nur bezüglich der größe
sondern auch in sachen temperatur und
sonneneinstrahlung sehr ähnlich
besonders ähnlich dazu heißt es in der
aktuellen studie nur vier durch transits
identifizierte planeten sind weniger als
1,25 ehrt radien groß besitzen weniger
als die zweifache erdmasse und kreisen
in der konservativen habitablen zone
ihrer sterne heißt also er kreist in
einem bereich um sein zentralgestirn der
ziemlich perfekt ist dabei ist diese
sensationelle entdeckung ein echter
glücksfall denn die software roboter
hatte keppler 16 49 c zunächst falsch
einsortiert der algorithmus wurde
eingesetzt um die daten des kepler
weltraumteleskops zu analysieren und
dieses gilt als der planetenjäger
schlechthin und das obwohl das teleskop
bereits vor zwei jahren abgeschaltet
worden war
noch sind nicht alle daten mehrfach
durchforstet es tauchen immer wieder
neue funde auf tausende sterne wurden
mit seiner hilfe beobachtet und dabei
nach klein helligkeitsschwankungen
gesucht etwa zwölf prozent der
verdunklung waren besonders spannend für
die fachwelt da sie vom vorüber
ziehenden exo planeten verursacht wurden
und genau darauf hatte es die
wissenschaftler abgesehen
doch die software hat den fall von
kepler 16 49 c wohl auf andere
astronomische prozesse getippt die
ebenfalls solche abdunklung verursachen
können so wurde der zwilling zunächst
aussortiert doch ein nasa team hatte
nachgehakt und fand den fehler nun in
den alten daten des kepler teleskops der
zwilling ist für die wissenschafts
community auf grund der tatsache auch
dass er nicht alleine ist besonders
spannend denn um den roten zwerg kreis
wohl noch ein weiterer planet dessen
orbit etwa halb so weit entfernt ist wie
der von kepler
16 49 c die fachleute sprechen von einer
neuen so viel resonanz das heißt dass
der eine planet in einer bestimmten zeit
neun umkreisen schafft und der andere
genau 4
doch diese resonanz erscheint den
fachleuten ungewöhnlich bislang kennen
wir von planeten bahn stärker resonanzen
wie etwa 2 2 1 oder 3 22 verhältnisse
möglicherweise spricht diese
beobachtungen dafür dass es noch einen
dritten planeten gibt der zwischen dem
eher zwilling und dem anderen planeten
kreist doch von ihm fehlt bislang jede
spur klar ist nur dass fachleute
weltweit mit hochdruck nach solchen
potenziell lebensfreundliche bedingungen
suchen
doch wie lebensfreundlich sind die
bedingungen auf dem exoplaneten keppler
16 49 c wirklich um das abzuschätzen
braucht es dringend noch weitere
informationen doch möglich scheint es
schon dass sich dort wie auf der erde
leben entwickeln könnte offen ist noch
ob keppler 16 49 c eine atmosphäre hat
und wie aktiv seien zentral stern ist
klar ist nur dass der ex über nicht in
einem engen orbit sein zentralgestirn
umkreist und für einen umlauf von nur 19
5 tagen braucht also im verhältnis zur
erde spricht ein ja ist da so knapp 20
tage lang also doch sehr sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr kurz doch rote zwerge am noch
einen
herausforderung sie sind bekannt für
ihre aktivität und ihre extremen
ausbrüche was potenzielles leben ja
eigentlich unmöglich machen könnte dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam
je mehr daten wir erhalten desto mehr
verdichten sich die belege dafür dass es
gerade um rote zwerge besonders viele
potenziell lebensfreundliche und ehrt
große exoplaneten gibt und dabei sind
etwa drei viertel aller sterne in
unserer kosmischen nachbarschaft rote
zwerge dazu der nasa wissenschafts
direktor thomas zu buchen
diese faszinierende fremde welt gibt uns
noch größere hoffnung dass dort draußen
unter den stern irgendwo eine zweite
erde auf ihre entdeckung wartet denn die
entdeckung von er zwilling man muss
sagen häufen sich und jetzt wird alles
anders das war das letzte video indem
wir bei einer einzelnen entdeckung eine
studie oder eine einzelne erkenntnis
berichtet haben diese video häppchen
sind geschichte wir machen tabula rasa
beenden diesen teil vom krieg summe ich
bin davon überzeugt jetzt brauchen wir
etwas anderes ab jetzt gehen wir mehr in
die tiefe wenn wir uns das nächste mal
mit exoplaneten beschäftigen dann machen
wir das grundlegend und zeigen
zahlreiche aspekte auf und legen viel
mehr wert auf das große ganze seid also
gespannt und schreibt eure meinung dazu
in die kommentare mit dem nächsten video
geht es los und dann montags mittwochs
und freitags bis dann bleibt dran